the contract agreement is basically you
and Rob and it's basically ring size 18
foot 16 ounce gloves both parties to
wear head guards but Rob it's keen on
four rounds I think three rounds will be
better 1700 people are going to be
coming to watch you and me and they're
going to want a bit more of a feast than
just the undercard and if that's a
disadvantage to you you have to knock me
out in round one
can make you feel happier with three
if you're happy keep interrupting me bro
and now you're [__] up my negotiation
I want to know what Rob's gonna say I'm
quite surprised I didn't really expect
you to come with so many particulars
there's only one though we'll go three
two minute
we do 18 foot ring
12 ounce minimum on the gloves no head
guards no top yeah I'll do that
where did all this call out come from I
know obviously you're competitors in the
market well three years ago
you were talking about kicking my ass on
some podcasts who's winning the fight
are you and Samuel Leeds
I'd back myself
nice because I've got some past skills
[Music]
and all I said is I said oh you think
you bit me I said would you put money on
that and he went yeah 50 Grand
I would go at me calling you out all
right let me ask you this if you're
being interviewed by Darren on his
podcast yeah and he says who wins in a
fight
you or Rob Moore you're not going to say
me are you you're Kush you're going to
say yeah it's just an innocent question
it was it was a question but you could
have said don't know but you didn't no
tell the truth he's probably bigger than
me but I mean you know like he's
probably going to be stronger than me
we'll find out we'll find out we'll find
out so did you just pull 50 grand out of
your head was that just a random number
yeah
well I thought if I bet real money that
I've got he won't be able to record it
so well you want to fight in talk
already yeah
well bang we need to change that now
then damn you were quick to do that
brother he thinks this through doesn't
he man 100 Grand some serious money I'm
gonna just change that 50 Grand to 100.
I'm glad we've got cameras not my
cameras though I probably edit this
100 Grand
good we can sign now if you're ready to
sign yeah sure you don't need your
lawyers
that just says Sam is that your real
signature
does that just say salmon it's a bit of
a squiggly sound is that your real scene
that's actually s leads that says okay
well this is my real season
that's a lot more juicy now yeah it's
very juicy yeah I think as all parties
are in agreement there is just one thing
left to do and that is a Face-Off
the food stamps yeah
[Music]
you look 60. you're not six right
he's one of those guys seven six three
anyway your hair's spiky yeah
[Music]